I haven't been in Dad's room in years.
That pose is so corny, Dad.
Why didn't we spend more time together?
Why didn't we talk to each other more?
Why didn't we do more...
Happy birthday.
A present?
It's a sample of my company's new product.
I'm sure you will love it, Aiko.
What is this?
This looks bad!
I'm going to take a look. You stay here.
Aiko!
It seems we're out of time.
Come with me!
-What?
-Hurry!
-What are you--
-The Burst.
The only person who can end this disaster
is you.
-What is--
-People are here to interfere.
-Let's go.
-What?
Wait! What?
Hey, new guy! Where did you go?
-He disappeared?
-Let's go!
What are you doing?
Tachibana, we have a package for you.
Are you here?
-What's going on?
-Buckle up.
What?
What is going on?
What is this all about?
-What did you do?
-Turned off your vitals monitor.
They can track you if it's on.
The target, Yuya Kanzaki,
has driven off with Aiko Tachibana.
We're in pursuit.
Damn! It's the Matter Defense HQ.
What? The Town? We can't get in there!
-What's he doing?
-Don't get too close!
We'll get spotted
if we force our way through.